I'm not sure I'll add a lot of
details cavale 10 we've already given
the essentials
so I'll try to do
something other than detail today is the
sixth time since November 2014 that
we've spoken about the projects
budget of member states of the euro zone
let's say I thought there
would only be 5
but circumstances have meant that I
'm here paul sixth time this time
I can assure you it's really the
last not only  the last
time I present his projects but also the
few times I address
you because I still have the best
hope that the next commission
can be validated under good
conditions by the European parliament
next week and can take  his
duties on December 1 with his
opinions we confirm our
commitment which was that of the
entire mandate for an intelligent application of
our common rules
based on an awareness of the
economic reality of  in each country as
well as in the euro zone as a
whole and I think that there is a
signature an approach which will remain that
of the juncker commission and which
I hope will continue in the future even
if it must of course change we
can  to note that much progress
has been made over the past five years
both economically and in terms of the
budget, and the President had said that
we are the last
chance committee I think that we took up this
challenge
, at least economically in
2014  aftermath of the crisis we
remember it without weighing very hard
today feeling growth is
certainly under pressure and talking about
last week but it remains
positive after six consecutive years
of expansion with an unemployment rate which
continues to decrease  even if it is
longer today and on the
budgetary level which concerns us
today the situation for once
it is very strongly improved in our
first opinion in November  mber 2014
only five countries and presenting compliant budgets
are today 9
there is no longer any member of the
euro zone which is borrowing on the
excessive deficit for the first time the
first time since 2002 and the
launch of the
laurent deficit  in the euro zone should remain
below 1% of GDP in 2020
I would remind you that in 2014 it was still
2.5 percent the public debt of the
zone, which was 95% in 2014, should be
further reduced to 85% next year
therefore a development which is more than
notable it is remarkable and it
shows the extent of the efforts which have been
made by the member states to
clean up their public finances within
the framework of the rules it also shows
that the commission has played its role
of spur  as a regulator it
finally demonstrates that it is quite possible to
reduce its public deficit while
supporting serious budgetary growth
and austerity
it is not the same thing we have
tried to demonstrate by a reading  e
intelligent and flexible of the rules I
remind you that at the first act was the
communication on flexibility
then January 13, 2015 until the end it
was our doctrine
today's opinions are of course important
the nine vehicles consider compliant
to the requirements of the pact things like that
were said germany ireland greece
and yes greece we nevertheless returned
rather successfully to the normal regime
cyprus lithuania luxembourg malta
the netherlands and austria two countries
are globally  compliant
it is the framework of estonia and
latvia which has done better in the past
it is like that in the case
of germany and the
netherlands we welcome the first steps towards a
budgetary policy that is more
expansive more  in any case, this
is excellent news for the
growth of these countries, of course, but
also for the euro zone as a whole,
but we also note that
their favorable budgetary situation would
enable them to  do more we
therefore invite these countries to support
investments for
growth even more and to make even more use
of the considerable leeway it
has
for 8 countries we note that the
draft budgets are at risk of
non-compliance mainly due
to  'a structural effort below
what is recommended by the council three
of them spain portugal and
belgium presented when a the
political situation draft
budgets based on
unchanged policies our policies seek
new governments will have to present
draft budgets updated as soon
as possible and we know that the
situations are not the same in
spain, portugal and belgium
the five other countries are france,
italy, slovenia, slovakia and
finland.
within this
category the situations are not
all the same
if belgium italy spain
france hardly it is necessary to dir  e to reduce
their public debt which is too
high portugal slovenia slovakia
and finland have either already reduced their
debts below the bar of 60% of
gdp
it is possible or are in the process of
reducing it at a rate that could
considered satisfactory
the situation of the structural deficits of
its states should be
examined again in the spring on the basis of the
final figures for 2019 of the
next spring reviews in
summary the commission today invites
its member states whose public debt
is high to continue
prudent budgetary policies and those who have
budgetary margins to use them
to increase investment in the
service of growth once again, and
it is exactly this
differentiated approach which can strengthen the euro area
and enable it to maximize its
growth potential
hungary romania clue
to dijon it was going back we do
again today
recommendations within the framework of the
significant deviation procedure
in both cases we make the same
observation that there is no action followed
by effect but it must be recognized that our
forecasts are more encouraging in
the case of hungary  and that they are
much
much less so in the case of
romania it is closer to a college of
brassy leaning in the spring but
since there is a new government in
romania we can also the guest will make
the necessary efforts to help  the
college leaned in the right direction
a pro european government must also
act in the direction of european rules
lastly concerning to distort all its
minds to conclude positively a
vessel is concluded said on abc
dynaction group to decide take advantage of it
ingrid bang bang bang un  little sad date
new grids which took office in july
aztec industry action to achieve
epolicy commitment to he had you buy
from shawn ouakam's medal of truth and night
where line is  that ready to build there
is excellent and the institutions
helped with a hot space of time for
your available brains
tatchou by positive for a blue jacket
tango swing odette investment and roses
it's about suitcases badri neil inglis
is strict in bed
since last show in  front of view of his
children
rice ascom since from idex crisis homeland and
from turbines we are all coming consider
el hajri no more loss or steendam
for other lives in wisches in cap town
ugly but all those for the flu
pipeau again from his  majesty sideman
boots at olso halmos lee lives date
commission carl probyn action built
where it will take the guen sproxy monday night
and political to kate positions from
dust at on found and we were on the
right side of the street
welcome under decision a week to
data software and five days now
crisis looks like there is a whole
different leap said integrity said john gobbi
commission a talent who considers as
close positives linked  are on the radar action
now it's time to call centers for pippo
has by the way spip
thank you for internal to them
still not say the last words in
English
thank you for your attention